uh
these won't get glazed this is just
this is going out the window what's up
everyone my name is brianna i'm a pastry
chef and today
going to be reviewing this betty crocker
mini donut factory i'm old school i love
a good fried doughnut and even just
judging by the box these things look
like just straight up cake i don't know
we'll see i'm kind of excited to see how
these turn out because i've made donuts
professionally for a few years now and
even worked at a donut shop so
you know
oh she's small comes with this cute
little piping bag and some piping tips
is cute i'm guessing so we can achieve
this cute little squiggles squiggles
it'd be nice if it came with some
sprinkles too but you know okay it's
smaller than a waffle maker which is
nice because having a lot of appliances
that are large is no fun i don't know
though to be called a donut factory and
have seven little compartments and my
dad's about to be like i love lucy just
banging these things out on a conveyor
belt i will give you the benefit of the
doubt miss betty you seem to know best
for most things so we shall see our
recipe book here comes with four
different recipes the one that really
called to my soul was the apple one with
cider glaze i just love it so we're
gonna make that one i'm gonna get all my
ingredients ready and we're gonna do the
damn thing get this factory going
all right so i have all my ingredients
here there aren't very many instructions
they're not very detailed it's literally
just hey these are all the ingredients
mix them together put them in the
machine you got donuts we're just gonna
put this in here
and get our mix on using an electric
mixer that is one of the very few steps
that they gave us use an electric mixer
i think we're good i have it preheating
it doesn't tell me in here in the little
recipe guide which light to look out for
but i'm assuming this little orange red
light means no i'm not ready yet and
when it's like yeah i'm ready it'll turn
green that's just you know what's going
on in my head it's also smoking right
now
it warned us in the instructions that it
might be smoky upon first use even after
wiping down um
so i'm not alarmed by this i'm alarmed
that this sticker says remove me before
using and i haven't yet so we're gonna
do that
it's green
so we're ready i would load this up but
this piping tip is a little small so i'm
guessing this is only for decorating
purposes so
we'll be using just a tablespoon scoop
that's how much it says to use
and putting one into each mold it
doesn't say whether to spray or grease
or anything so we're just going straight
in
oh she's sizzling okay i kind of feel
like this is like a evil skeever i think
that's what they're called this seems
like it would be cleaner in a piping bag
so if you have one go for it but miss
betty didn't tell us to pipe so i'm
gonna listen to miss betty it has these
little prongs at the top so it'll make a
little donut hole for us because she's
not too holy yet i don't know let me
tell you i'm working right now and this
is just the first round this thing is
hot it tells me this will make 48 mini
donuts
i'm not ready for that this says to bake
for two to three minutes or until golden
brown so i'm gonna set a timer
and we will check it in two minutes i'll
start on the on the low side just to be
safe it's still pretty smoky and i don't
know if that's like steam from it
cooking the donuts now or if this is
just like
i'm warming up to you getting to know
you type of steam um as a machine so
i don't know but it smells good i'm
smelling that it's actually baking it or
steaming it or whatever this is
how i was cooking it and we're ready
oh
what are y'all doing it says to use a
wooden or rubber spatula to get them out
interesting
they're looking a little
like me in august a little brown
maybe even a little sunburnt the top
looks nice but the brown the bottom is
very brown it's kind of crispy even
compared to the top these definitely
just look like little cake
little cakes little baby bundt cakes
almost not so much as donuts this is
also why i think piping would be a much
better idea than just tablespooning it
in there because
then you get all this although it looks
yummy i'm not going to lie the
crunchiness is calling to me right now
and i kind of want to try it looks like
it has a good nugget of apple
[Music]
it's hot
no regrets
okay
i'm not gonna lie although i just burned
the hell out of my mouth
it's good like i'm actually kind of
shocked i will say though there's one
thing missing from this donut and it's a
hole i thought that with this little
setup it would help push the dough out
of the way and get rid of that but
none of them have a hole i'm going to
load this up do some more factory work
and then we'll get our glaze going and
give it a final judgment so the second
batch is in here now i don't think i'm
going to get a hold this time around as
hard as i tried i could still see that
once it hit that like hot uh surface
the dough just started to spread all
right it's time to open these up let's
see if there's any difference this time
around
ciao
what oh it's sticking here what's
happening
i only did a tablespoon i promise i
followed directions but
this is just so webbed
i promise i'm doing my best to make
these donuts work to make miss betty
proud
but things are just getting worse so i'm
gonna give it one more chance and i
switched out the piping tip to this nice
round one think you use this to make
like cute little rose petals gonna use
the bag i'm gonna pipe it in i'm going
to
use less batter and i'm hoping we get
this factory going a lot better this is
trial number three i have my piping bag
my tip i'm really hoping this tip kind
of helps us at a nice angle so we can
like go right around the hole that's
what i'm hoping and thinking we're
preheated we're ready to go we're going
to load her up and cross our fingers and
our toes i've been doing two minutes but
they've been so brown i kind of just
want to go with one so we're going to
set a one minute timer i'm going to stop
dripping batter everywhere and then
we'll see but we're going to give it a
look
just just look at it
it's just they're so beautiful i'm such
a proud mama they're perfect they're not
too brown
there's no like spillage anywhere
and best of all
there's a hole
she's holy okay i'm happy with these it
took a few tries but we got there don't
know how that would hold up in a regular
donut factory
but
we made it so they look better let's
make sure that they taste better too
hopefully
they definitely do it's not a great
taste overall though
it's kind of bland there's no apple in
this one somehow so i'm not getting any
cinnamon i'm not getting any bite of the
apple no caramelization from any of that
mixture
i'll give this like a c minus
so
we're gonna let these cool off a little
bit get our glaze made and
uh
these won't get glazed this is just
this is going out the window so overall
it wasn't the best experience it wasn't
really a donut it's definitely more of a
cakey kind of flavor
not that good donut fried bite that we
all enjoy i'm so sorry miss betty but i
have to give you a thumbs down
i'm so sorry i wanted to give you a
thumbs up but my heart i
my heart of hearts i just can't thank
you guys for watching my gadget review
of the betty crocker mini donut factory
if you want to see me review more betty
crocker gadgets comment below but until
then you can follow me on instagram at
breezyjacks
bye
oh yes
you